let's look at rumble
rumble were the brave ones they stood up
and they said they they signed me they
come up they said look we believe in you
we believe what you're saying today they
signed me when no one else would look
what happened to the stock price
30
on a stock in a bear market in a
recession
like people are paying attention to this
[ __ ] so this is all coming they're just
waiting for public sentiment to shift
and it's shifting in real time i have my
own team monitoring social media
comments in real time
at the height of the [ __ ] storm at the
true height of the shitstorm it was 50
50. it's currently 80 20.
it's it it's only going one way they
can't the problem with the social media
companies in the matrix they fired all
their bullets they can't start printing
again i'm a misogynist i can't get the
daily mail to do a new story on how i'm
dangerous they've done it all they've
run out of ammo and i'm still alive
they've emptied the clip and it hurt me
but i got up
and now they're like click click [ __ ]
what else are they gonna do what are
they gonna do what are they gonna say
about me now can i tell you why sure
because you talk about institutions
being
behind certain high-profile individuals
saints that as you referred to while joe
rogan you couldn't cancel joe because
ufc is behind him or chapelle
he was
he was 12 to 24 months away he wasn't
there yeah no no not yet yeah but the
institution it's not a formal
institution but it's certainly an
institution is you've won the hearts and
minds of young men right across the
planet right and even if you get
cancelled on social media
you still have
millions and millions of young men
that's like where's date
and this is why they killed me early
they killed me early because they knew i
was going to get to this station status
but the problem they don't understand is
that inside of every single young man
there's a rebel
whether it's the punk rock rebels
whether whatever it is every single
young man has a degree of rebel in him
so when you take their hero and martyr
him what does that do it solidifies the
rebel status i've had you wouldn't
believe i've had 17 year old kids from
slovenia
email me trying to give me their life
savings of two and a half thousand
dollars
anything to help you
the amount of money they're trying to i
like bro i don't need money thank you
these kids will do anything to keep me
alive like it's true belief it's true
belief that's why they tried to
annihilate me they thought we have to
annihilate him now he's going to get to
a point where he can't be annihilated
but it didn't work in fact it re it
re-solidified it i had to find other
platforms perhaps it slowed it down
whatever but the hearts and minds are
still there there was a video that was
on my instagram of when i went to
slovenia slovenia i've never been
slovenia in my life i turned up in the
chiron i parked outside a hotel and you
guys seen it there are
five or ten thousand people outside the
hotel screaming top g top g top g i'm in
the room with these two chicks they're
looking at me and look at each other
like
[ __ ] i was like you're getting top g
tonight
they were standing there for hours we
had to call the police to like you it's
a different level of movement and that's
what they're scared of and i also want
to say this publicly to them because i
believe they are watching
i'm not the enemy to the systematic
powers i i'm actually very intelligent
when you're saying earlier about logan
knowing his place i'm not here to try
and become king of earth i'm not here to
get suicided i'm not here to do any of
that but i do have a huge contingent of
young men who believe in me and i do
understand that the things i'm teaching
them are good for them and by extension
it will be good for society i'm not
trying to take over the world right i'm
not trying to do that because i don't
want to end up in a position where i'm
against people who run the world i'm not
stupid
but
their attack has failed
so now they have to sit and if they have
a brain analyze what they're going to do
next saint status is coming one way or
another i truly and not really believe
that i'm already having conversations
with very important people and rumble
were the first people who stood up to me
and said you know what we've got your
back 100
including financially and they offered
me a huge financial incentive i said you
know what
don't worry about that let me just you
keep the stocks don't worry about it
boom because i don't need money and when
you don't need money it also puts you in
a very very powerful position it's very
it's very rare you find a man who has
that much influence who doesn't want
money i don't want money i believe in
what you're saying let's do it
i believe in this let's do it i don't
need money i believe it i i really
believe and perhaps you'll disagree with
me because you have more money than i do
once you get past a certain number of
million life's the same
what are you gonna buy how many steaks
can you eat
like i don't gamble i don't take drugs
like you you eat vodka's cheap
i have my house i have 27 cars there are
nothing to buy
i have diamond watches i i i'm really
although i talk about making money and i
talk like i'm a money uh oriented person
i do that because you cannot truly
escape from the matrix if you're poor
because they use as a control mechanism
against you but once you get past that
it doesn't matter if you have 50 million
or 75 million your life's the same 400
million your life's the same i don't
need more money it's not interesting to
me what's interesting to me is living a
life that's true to god i like being
able to go to sleep at night knowing i'm
happy with myself and who i am i like
knowing the things i say on podcasts are
a good genuine influence on the world i
like if something bad happens to me
which happens to everybody i can go to
sleep knowing that karma's going to
reward me because i'm a positive
influence i don't need to sell my soul
for money this is the thing that logan
does not yet understand he still thinks
selling his soul's worth it it's not
worth it for money i don't need money
it's not about money for me on any level
it never will be so i do believe st
status is coming
you have a very very powerful point
and also
this is why you have a level of power
control why don't you have right you you
you have a certain status and power
you're right i don't yet have but i do
certainly not really believe it's coming
just because of the feedback i've had
it's been absolutely monumental on the
day of my banning i got 94 000 emails
94 000 people took time out of their
life to just email me support
it's insane it says they haven't they
haven't tricked anybody they've just
proved me right if you enjoyed this
video and you want to watch the entire
podcast click over here and if you want
to be connected with experts influencers
such as kiyosaki tate connolly palmeteri
myself and others download the app
minect where you get a chance to connect
with these folks by the minute you get
to buy the minute or have face times
with them 15 minutes ask them any
questions you may want to have download
the admin act and start connecting with
influencers and experts today
you